je vous présente le plus ancien album de
photographies conservés aux archives
départementales de la réunion intitulée
album des vues de bourbon des ti à
messieurs des sucriers et négociants de
la réunion il a été réalisée par les
photographes de paris par an et rondeau
édité en une centaine d'exemplaires il
est mis en vente en novembre 1861 deux
exemplaires sont parvenus dans les fonds
des archives départementales de format
italien il s'agit d' album de grande
taille contenant 22 tirages noir et
blanc sur papier ovale coller sur carton
et légendes et à la main les artistes de
paris se sont attachés à vous produire
des vues de monuments et de paysage de
saint denis et sainte marie saint pierre
et salazie cependant il n'existe aucune
scène de jambes
aucun type physique toute présence
humaine difficile à fixer semble manier
des paysages urbains ou ruraux reproduit
par les deux artistes
cet album marque une étape importante
dans l'histoire de la photographie à la
réunion en effet elle correspond à
l'apparition des premières
de la colonie en 1843 un certain
bertrand s'installe à saint denis et il
ouvre le premier atelier photographique
connu dans l'île bertrand réalise des
daguerréotypes surtout des portraits de
notables malheureusement il n'existe
actuellement aucun document de ce type
dans les fonds des archives beaucoup
étaient conservées dans des collections
privées au cours des années 1850
de nombreux ateliers ont pignon sur rue
dans à saint-denis qu'à saint pierre
comme en europe les photographes sont
avant tout des portraitistes en effet
grâce à la photographie l'art du
portrait autrefois réservé à une élite
devient accessible au plus grand nombre
la mode est alors aux portraits de
petits formats connu sous le nom de
cartes de visite reproductive par de
très nombreux exemplaires il monde un
personnage en buste ou en pied parfois
installées dans un décor inspiré de
tableau avec mobilier de style effet de
draperies ou encore des accessoires
les archives départementales possède
quelques exemples de ces premiers
portraits notamment dans l'album de
caroline viard et dans les fonds de
tourisme on range en 1862 lors de la
première exposition universelle à
londres un album de parents et rondeau
figurent parmi les produits envoyés par
la réunion ainsi les autorités de la
colonie saisissent l'opportunité de ce
nouveau médium pour faire la promotion
de la colonie en